hippopotamus
that scene from the Netflix drama narcos
Mexico portrays a character's harrowing
encounter with the notorious Colombian
drug lord Pablo Escobar and as you saw
there it features a nod to the cocaine
kingpin's vast collection of exotic
animals including hippos he imported
from Africa Escobar was killed in 1993
but 30 years later the hippos have
multiplied to where they've become
something of a local nuisance we checked
in on this story back in 2019 and now
Colombian officials are weighing a new
option to limit these animals that
represent a violent chapter in that
nation's history Manuel bojorquez has
the story
what was once just a handful of hippos
is now more than a hundred along
Colombia's Magdalena River we visited
here in 2019. there are fishing villages
that dot the river and we just bought it
what appears to be a hippo who is now
trying to hide from us
there it is there it is
wow the animals native to Africa were
originally brought here as pets by the
infamous drug lord Pablo Escobar since
his death the hippos have flourished
they have no natural predators and ample
food and water but they are considered
an invasive species and are often seen
encroaching on areas populated by people
biologist David echeveri works with
cornare the environmental agency in
charge of tracking and managing the
hippos in the region have there been
close calls or other incidents between
hippos and people since the last time we
saw you yes we have two accidents with
two accidents the two people survive
um
so miraculously people survived an
encountered us when we visited echeverry
helped us get an up close look at just
how fearsome these animals can be
so he's saying we're getting as close as
we can to these hippos in the main Lake
here
you have to be here
a bit of a crash course and how to get
close to these creatures is not to get
too close of course he says they may
come out of the water to let us know
we're on their territory and if they
charge running a zigzag motion because
they can only run in a straight line
[Music]
they're letting us know that
they know we're here in the past efforts
to sterilize them have proven difficult
and cost prohibitive and culling the
herd is unpopular now Colombian
environmental officials are considering
a plan to lure and trap 70 of the hippos
and then relocate them to sanctuaries in
countries like Mexico and India will the
plan work
yes the plan works but it's complex
because the hippo's behavior is
unpredictable echevery says so for now a
country that has worked to move Beyond a
drug Lord's brutal Legacy hopes to have
found the solution for one big part of
it for CBS Saturday morning I'm Manuel
bojorquez
we've got a note to self at least if a
hippo's Chasing You zigzag don't no
don't run in a straight line right
zigzag yeah majestic creatures dangerous